you
what I love about working in web
development specifically the front end
is that it's constantly moving and
evolving there's always new things to
learn and I think that's something you
can't say about a lot of other
professions every now and then you have
another framework on other technology or
something completely changes like gay
location just available under secure
connections for instance which wasn't
there before but even with the constant
changes around you have a way to to
build a robust and resilient
architecture and structure to overcome
those changes when I code something I
can see the fruits of my labor right
away I love hitting the refresh button I
like the opportunity to continue
learning because it is an ever-changing
environment at the hands we host online
portfolios so it's awesome being able to
make like a positive measurable impact
on people's lives I love that I get to
meet people I get to travel I get to
talk about things I get to go and have a
drink you know coffee and discuss ideas
and maybe next year we will be talking
about something completely different
the assistance for cascading style
sheets CSS stands for centering
sometimes CSS from me stands for
wellness the last bit of elegance and
finesse and let the old man's son was
saying centring stuff sometimes but it's
a my talk was all about how we've fixed
that with flex box and grid so hopefully
we can send stuff all the time when we
want it clever smart and stunning people
can sleep soundly because i know that
i'm using web standards and that i'm
quoting in a way that is faster download
easy to understand and also that people
can take a look at and learn from my
code
you